do a ski yeah
everything's good that's okay i'll do a
nice block here
see this is all i'm going to show you it
and watch
how it's all contained in me in this
little spot here
right so it's all mechanical
[Music]
i'm hoping the form looks okay
now especially this one you see i'm in a
posture i've got everything right
but i'm here i'm not expanding anywhere
so it's all within my circle
so you can't get coke you you can't get
this
super power if you're
as big as the form is
if you expand what jenny was doing and
she was going in and out of it but
she's only had one lesson at it but if
you sort of like
span hey
hey it becomes joyful
it becomes
you see the difference perhaps you can't
you know
be honest i don't mind if you sound crap
i'll go home now
um oh i shouldn't say that's on film
if you can hey go outside
yourself
this joy
so when you're up here what i've
actually pushed out and expanded
out there to those who are prepared to
be a little bit more flaky like me
and say well if i touch heaven
and now bring heaven down with me
you've got a lot of power you can bring
from up there
you know there's a lot of power but if
you're here
in just your posture all you've got is
what you can create
with your body
look here so when i watched john his
hands were quite close to his head
so the first thing you need to do
is to expand before you do it and when
you go up
you've got to push up you might think
that you i'm talking about stretching
it's not stretching
but the technical way is you have to
stretch first
but if you go too far it means that your
balance
you've lost your mass so your mass is
here
you stretch to your maximum but you
don't let it waver
if you stretch to your maximum and then
you let it drop a little bit
you've lost the heaven because you
haven't got any more heaven now
because you just unplugged that
connection
i saw i'm grateful that you come
but i also apologize for those who don't
believe in spiritual stuff
because to me unless you can believe
that on your own
you're not going to find what it is
that osensei wanted us to have
[Music]
all these people out there going me
sound she they're doing a really good
sharp
form but
when they're old well they have the
spiritual understanding of what it was
like to
experience that thrust experience that
block
experience that turn experience that
lift
experience the turn
so what i said in the hole
does it feel like paul is pulling my joe
yes but i'm
rooted here so i've got a connection
between
mass paul pulling my joe
so i'm expanding ex thinking that
and now i can bring paul's energy
over there to that i don't let this drop
and lose i keep it going
and then i bring it back in i bring this
energy
back in so i never lose the energy it's
a little bit like i'm on turbo boost
and i don't take my foot off the
throttle
so the moment i expand
it doesn't die and that's what makes a
carter
rather
so i think you can see it getting to
it's a different matter